hey guys Pete here just finished the
first watch of twin peak season 3 part 6
and this is going to be a top moment
sort of reaction video not my normal
recap the review I'll be coming out with
that
shortly afterwards but I wanted to do
this one first because I'm kind of
nursing a cold and I didn't want to put
off putting something out if you haven't
watched part 6 yet this will be your
spoiler warning everything past this
part will spoil the episode so okay this
was a pretty good episode I really liked
it on first watch and the first moment
that stood out were dougie coupe moments
there's two separate parts that I
absolutely laughed at and that one was
when he was with sunny Jim and sunny
Jim's room and he had sort of the
clapper battle with the light I was
cracking up and then we saw him at the
table with his wife Jamie II and she
pulled out the picture of Jade and he
said he started smiling and said JJ gave
two rides so that was a really good one
speaking of Jamie she had a pretty
awesome moment and whenever she gave
this speech to these two guys that were
pretty funny-looking that she met at the
park she talks about the dark aids like
we live in the Dark Age and it was
really cool and I really enjoyed the way
she shuffled off to the car just like
completely over it in the whole
situation but she did pay back the guys
sort of and I think that that would hold
them off next moment was mr. Todd this
is the guy in Las Vegas that we met
earlier he's sitting there looking at
his computer and all of a sudden the Red
Square pops up he clears it really
quickly but then he goes straight to his
safe and pulls out an envelope he then
passes the envelope off and the next guy
who gets it is the next moment he's
credited as Ike the spike and he is a
dwarf he might have noticed and has a
really cool theme song that they play
whenever he's on and we saw as he went
to Lorraine's office that he is quite a
be proficient killer so he now has
Dougie's photo the real
nice photo actually not dougie coups but
I don't think that'll slow him down and
I'm sure that we're going to see him in
the upcoming episodes another new
character well we had seen him briefly
in the Roadhouse but we get to know him
a lot better in this episode is red if I
now that red is Richard horns
distributor he's bringing this drug in
from up north in Canada and his little I
guess you would call it karate he was
sort of doing some karate there when he
was talking to Richard horn at first was
hilarious is grabbing his liver saying
he had liver problems and then he did
this coin flip trick where he flips the
coin a dime and you know it spins around
us in the air and then it's in Richard
horns mouth and then it's back in his
hand that was definitely classic and I
really am intrigued by the character
read as a result of that and Richard
horn of course is completely zooted off
this new batch of drugs and he decides
to run a red light because he can't be
bothered to stop and he runs over a
child and I'll speak a little bit more
about that later but yeah he just drives
off and then we see him later sort of
give a half-assed clean to his to the
grill on his truck to wipe off the blood
Frank Truman and Doris had a moment
there Doris was her usual self and she
was upset
with Frank he was understanding and
whatever like he usually is but we find
out that from the switchboard operator
that they had a child who had committed
suicide and Doris hadn't been that way
prior to that we also found out here the
chat is even a bigger douchebag than we
originally realized yeah he just seems
to be one of those people that you love
to hate and that's his purpose I mean he
the way he talked about their son
killing himself because he couldn't take
being a soldier
while mocking the guy not too much
there's a seem to be too many redeeming
qualities to Deputy Chad the next big
one is one that I had been waiting for
and we did finally arrived at the
trout first moment we had there was we
met another character who was new who
happens to live with somebody named
Linda now of course this is most
definitely the Linda that the giant was
referring to we didn't learn much about
her but we did find out that she is in
an electric wheelchair and that she's
getting assistance for the government
but it's not coming fast enough
according to this guy who's talking to
call you see the call goes into town
just about every day and also that he's
been smoking for 75 years every damn day
while he's there we see him sitting on a
bench with the double our to-go cup and
he witnesses the hit-and-run that
richard horn committed and we see that
his trip to wherever he went when he was
a child may be responsible for he
basically seems like this you know when
the kid dies he sees what looks like a
yellow light it could be a spirit or the
electricity whatever you want to say
there we see that leave the kid and this
is interesting because like I said we
know that he was abducted whenever he
was a child with the log lady and he may
have brought this power back and you
know that's definitely similar to what
we see going on with dougie coupe you
know agent Cooper and Dougie's life
right now he's not all there but he can
see certain things that helped him along
the way
the next big moment was hawk he drops a
coin in the bathroom a buffalo head coin
as he goes to pick it up he notices that
there's a stamp on the door of the stall
that says Nez Perce manufacturing now
that's his heritage he's in that he's
from the Nez Perce tribe that's a Native
American tribe that you probably heard
about if you read the secret history but
once he notices that he decides to look
up and he sees that something's missing
there's some missing screws at the top
of the door and he goes a little bit
deeper tears the panel off and he finds
pages now I don't want to do a whole lot
of speculating on this video because I
just watched it for the first time and I
haven't really been able to piece things
together but what stood out
me at first glance was these were notes
or pages from Laura Palmer's diary
particularly those that Amy had told her
to write you know the good Dale is in
the lodge
now why would those be there well if you
remember Mike who was then you know in
his Philip Michael draws one on man
persona whatever you want to call it was
in one of these stalls before the whole
Leland thing got you know figured out so
I'm going to look into that a little bit
more and see but if I had to make a snap
guess without really reeling in anything
I'm feeling like that might put those
pages in that door a long time ago and
his you know this coin and everything
set things in motion for Hawk to find
them now Albert is still one of the
greatest Twin Peaks characters of all
time we run into him going out in the
ring under you know orders from deputy
Cole we got a deputy director Cole and
we get a little back influence with them
but the best moment just pure Albert
moment as I he's going in with the
umbrella he's like [ __ ] Gene Kelly you
[ __ ] you know for singing in the
rain or whatever but yeah then we get
the biggest moment of the entire thing
we get what we have all the waiting for
since the Blue Rose scene with agent
Cole and Albert we find out the woman
that he wanted to talk to was in fact
Diane he says Diane laura dern turns
around she has a strange blonde wig on
she's smoking a cigarette and it looks
like she's drinking martinis or
something along that line what does it
all mean we don't really know because
that's all we do is we got the reveal
but nothing more so those were my top
moments tell me in the comments what you
thought your top moments were and which
ones you're most excited about I will be
like I said I wanted to put this out
first because I have had a cold and it's
a little bit harder to work straight
through so it was afraid I wouldn't get
the recap and review out until you know
a little bit later so we have this we
can start from there I may do it like
this in the future
then you know will do I'll be going
through the regular thing I'll be doing
recap and review bonus video if
necessary Q&A later in the week and you
know just see how it goes this let this
past weekend had a couple videos I
didn't get out I had some bad news where
I had a really close friend who passed
away and kind of threw off my Saturday
and Sunday but those are on the back
burner that will be coming out at some
point so let me know what you think
leave any questions comments reactions
whatever you got in the in the comments
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel for more
Twin Peaks videos and thanks so much for
watching I'll talk to you soon